as a newer texture that reviews
smartphones we've been really
considering ordering the Galaxy fold to
make a review video in a few comparisons
but the recent news of the fold breaking
is the final nail in the coffin so no
we're not ordering one and it's not just
due to the fold gate issues we actually
have a few reasons why we're not going
to buy one the first and most important
reason is that we honestly don't think
it's going to be a popular phone
sure Galaxy fold videos are blowing up
on YouTube because of all the issues but
what's the hype dies down now many
people are gonna care anymore and that's
because most of the views on Galaxy fold
videos are from people who know they
won't be buying one anyway I mean it
costs two thousand dollars and most
people including us complained about
thousand-dollar phones we review tech
products so we're basically required to
spend money on expensive phones a few
different iPads and top-of-the-line 5ki
Mac's but two thousand dollars for an
Android phone has you thinking twice and
not only that but there are many things
that are really impractical with the
fold first of all it's incredibly thick
when folded it measures out to fifteen
point five millimeters basically twice
as thick as the Galaxy S ten plus it's
like sticking two of them in one pocket
not very comfortable or attractive if
you think the SN plus is a long phone
while in your pocket the fold is three
point three millimeters longer so it'll
probably stick out of most pant pockets
the point is that it's not very
practical for carrying around and it
doesn't fold flat either there's a
noticeable gap between both pieces so if
you lay it flat on a table the screen
will sit and an angle and don't get me
started on the front since the phone is
so long it can only fit a four point six
inch display even with the 21 by nine
aspect ratio there are large sections of
the front that are unused so it looks
pretty ugly compared to most smart
phones these days and you obviously will
be using the front display a lot for
things like check-in notifications and
quickly replying to texts now the
folding mechanism seems great and
basically every tech reviewer has been
impressed by it but the problem isn't
the display itself since it folds it's
not glass and you do see a crease down
the center which I honestly don't think
is a big deal since people will get used
to it the problem is that there's no
water resistance and since the display
has the bend it's not scratch resistant
reviewers are already showing a few
dings and scratches on the display after
only a few days you're basically gonna
have to take more care of this phone
than any other phone on the market and
with so many review units breaking or
thereby peeling off the screen protector
that's actually not a screen protector
or by it just breaking by itself it's
going to be even harder to justify
spending $2,000 the point is that the
Galaxy fold is one of the most
impractical smart phones on the market
you've got to make a lot of compromises
if you decide to buy it the main selling
points are actually the fact that it's
$2,000 which is ironic in the large
tablet size display which at 7.3 inches
is almost as big as the iPad Mini 7.9
inch display in in reality the display
is great especially for playing games
like Lou showed us in his gaming video
and if you're trying to watch videos on
YouTube since the aspect ratio is so
squared the black bars on the top and
bottom will be huge especially if
there's videos posted in the 21 by 9
aspect ratio so is it worth dealing with
all these other issues to get that
screen I honestly don't think so I think
it's great that Simpson took the bold
step of doing this first and I know that
future iterations of the fold will solve
some of these issues but for now it's
really not worth buying unless you've
got too much cash to care and that's why
we will be ordering one in for review
it's just too expensive and there are
too many drawbacks for the mass market
to buy it after a couple of weeks the
hype will die down and in the end it'll
just be a big waste of money both from
our perspective as reviewers and to
those who may actually buy one and have
lots of issues with it if you disagree
with this point of view let me know in
the comments section below what you
think about the new Galaxy fold make
sure you hit that sub button if you
haven't already and we'll see you in the
next video
[Music]